around 700 million years ago our planet
started to cool
[Music]
it was the beginning of an ice age
no one's quite sure why it happened but
it seems that our entire world was
plunged into an interminable winter
some scientists have called it a time of
snowball earth because a whole planet
may have appeared as an icy ball others
believed that the earth was cold but not
completely frozen today the average
surface temperature of the planet around
the world it's 15 degrees Celsius 700
million years ago it was much cooler
it's tough his temperature plummeted to
minus 55 or degrees Celsius most of the
sun's heat was reflected back to space
it looked like the earth might never
heat up again but clearly something
happened it was volcanoes that came to
the rescue
they erupted with tremendous force even
blasting through the ice sheets that
covered much of the plan
it must have been an extraordinary time
the nearest we've experienced was in
2004 when an eruption was filmed busting
through an ice sheet in central Aislinn
this is what would have happened
millions of years ago but on a global
scale the heat from volcanoes would have
melted holes in the ice
but that's not what saved our planet it
was the tons of carbon dioxide gas it
released that did the trick
as volcanoes continue to erupt levels of
carbon dioxide steadily built up in the
atmosphere until around 650 million
years ago the layer of carbon dioxide
became so thick that it trapped enough
heat to release the planet from his
endless winter at last a thaw began
fierce storms upended the planet and us
cold and slushy climate began to warm in
just a few hundred years temperatures
would rise dramatically and earth would
never be the same
fortunately over time a planet's climate
stabilized and earth slowly returned to
normal volcanoes had set the stage for a
dynamic new year